oggi mi sento un po come all'esame di
maturità o quella tensione noda andare
fuori tema
perché perché i temi leadership and
artificial intelligence possono essere
trattati se volete in modo scontato
banale ne parliamo quotidianamente a
casa con i parenti con amici
no chi dividerà il futuro e volevo
interpretare invece questi due temi
collegandoli a quelli che a quello che è
un tema molto importante cioè come
strutturare una economia digitale per il
nostro paese e la domanda l'ha
introdotta nicoletta abbiamo la capacità
per costruire un'economia digitale nel
nostro paese e voglio partire da quelli
che sono gli imprenditori che hanno
fatto la storia l'economia del nostro
paese
voglio partire da imprenditori locali
come vedete enzo ferrari ma voglio anche
collegare questo tema al confronto con
chi ha fatto l'economia digitale a
livello mondiale e ho messo di fianco a
enzo ferrari una faccia che ovviamente
non conoscete henry ford
riprendo il tema fra qualche minuto
un altro tema di cui voglio parlare però
altrimenti rischio come dicevo di andare
fuori tema è artificial intelligence e
c'è un momento storico della vita che mi
ha fatto anche sorridere quando mio
professore di statistica dell'università
mi assegnò il titolo della tesi che
aveva a che fare con
l'artificiale intelligence vent'anni fa
quando non era un tema così diciamo
mainstream come adesso e mi disse
attenzione perché quando tratterà in
questo tema devi proprio dirgli
artificial intelligence
qual è il suo obiettivo perché di per sé
come intelligenza non è poi così
intelligente devi dargli quella che
tecnicamente si chiama funzione
obiettivo e volevo cercare di spiegarvi
senza entrare nei dettagli tecnici che
cos'è una funzione obiettivo cioè come
dobbiamo dire alla decisione
intelligence di fare qualcosa
volevo spiegarlo con un esempio di
filosofia etica
questo esempio che viene fatto
nell'immagine da un papà con il suo
bambino è un esempio molto noto
l'esempio del carrello del treno viene
chiesto al bambino di decidere di fronte
a uno scambio dove dirigerà il treno
sulla sinistra
abbiamo la nonna la mamma legata al
binario sulla destra abbiamo cinque
persone sconosciute a questo bambino è
la domanda che gli viene imposta e dove
orienti il treno
questa domanda è stata come dire tornata
in auge in questo momento per via delle
auto a guida autonoma e pensiamo un
attimo al tema riportato al contesto di
un'auto guida autonoma che guida da sola
ma per strada un bambino attraversa la
strada e l'auto deve decidere che cosa
fare
i problemi sono molteplici perché
istintivamente l'intelligenza umana
tende a scattarla l'intelligenza
artificiale potrebbe dire no non lo
scarto perché se vado dall'altra parte
sopraggiunge un'altra macchina con altre
persone a bordo il rischio di fare
peggio
questo tema è stato trattato credo in
maniera brillante da una ricercatrice
dell'università di bologna che peraltro
ha fatto scuola sul tema con
l'introduzione di un concetto che è la
manopola etica ecco fate un conto di
avere di fianco al condizionatore no un
pomello con anche digitale se volete
caccia di qualche tipo che consente di
settare questa manopola etica su tre
livelli o riprendendo il concetto che
dicevo prima su tre funzioni obiettivo
diverse la prima egoista la seconda
altruista la terza neutra vuole parole
dobbiamo cercare di dire secondo questa
tesi di ricerca
qual è la funzione obiettivo al
artificialmente alle genti che sta
guidando la nostra macchina e guidare ha
molto a che vedere in questo esempio con
l'auto ma anche molto a che vedere con
la leadership come noi interpretiamo
quelli che sono i nostri obiettivi come
vogliamo guidare non stessi la nostra
impresa ma anche l'economia del paese e
quindi torniamo a il tema torniamo a
leadership economica e le funzioni
obiettivo che ci dobbiamo dare come
sistema paese
credo che come bolognesi questa foto sia
estremamente evocativa ed evocativa del
dna che ci contraddistingue evocativa
del funzione obiettivo che nei tempi dal
medioevo a oggi ha contraddistinto la
nostra economia ma perché perché siamo
vittime della sindrome del palio di
siena
no vogliamo vincere contro l'avversario
più vicino ci interessa ben poco
primeggiare a livello mondiale
l'importante è battere il contradaiolo
di fianco all importante battere il
comune di fianco nella foto dell'epoca
l'importante era avere la torre più
elevata è questo la dice lunga sul dna e
sul tipo di economia che abbiamo creato
perché poi facciamo riferimento di nuovo
no al confronto tra le due economie
cerchiamo di capire come hanno
influenzato la nostra storia economica è
la funzione obiettivo di ford qual era
non so quanti di voi hanno studiato la
storia economica dell'auto ma fort disse
voglio costruire la ford t per dare una
macchina a tutti vogliono impresa su
scala globale
quello era il suo obiettivo beh enzo
ferrari che
riconosceremo ha fatto un azienda che è
un marchio tra i top 100 al mondo un
obiettivo molto diversa è partito con le
corse ha detto io voglio vincere in
pista e poi a un certo punto detto sai
che c'è facciamo anche due automobili
belle e lussuose e veloci e obiettivo
completamente diverso
mi hanno detto che forse al docente
gente di lamborghini in sala qui ho
fatto un adattamento veloce lo speech
se pensate come è nata a lamborghini è
un alterco tra i due imprenditori
tu fai trattori che sembrava fa
rifrattori e lui ha detto e allora io
fondo la automobili lamborghini
cioè siamo una terra fatta così che più
che essere guidata da intelligenze
particolari e passione e istinto e
voglia di combattere sul territorio
e questo che cosa ci ha lasciato nel
corso dei secoli che cosa ha prodotto
beh ha prodotto i distretti industriali
trovo affascinante che questa non è una
caratteristica solo del nostro
territorio
no emiliano romagnolo è proprio una
caratteristica italiana
abbiamo distretti industriali che presi
singolarmente possono addirittura
rappresentare delle macro aziende se
tutte le aziende della motor valley
fossero unite probabilmente troveremo un
colosso che può competere a livello
mondiale con giapponesi toyota con i
tedeschi di audi volkswagen
e invece no invece abbiamo questa
parcellizzazione e questa economia che è
guidata da questa passione da questa
funzione obiettivo che è legata al fare
meglio del vicino
trovo oltremodo interessante che la
rappresentazione dei distretti
industriali non l'abbiamo inventata noi
cioè noi l'abbiamo costruita senza
saperlo non a tavolino e poi è arrivato
un economista americano marshall che nel
1920 ha detto sai che c'è guardando
l'economia dei vari paesi del mondo
ho trovato questa anomalia l'italia è
molto brava ed è molto brava tramite un
meccanismo che è il distretto
industriale quindi persone che sono
abituate a
disegnare a tavolino ecosistemi e
crescita hanno identificato quella che
era nei fatti un anomalia del tutto
italiana con questa anomalia
con questa capacità di fare leadership
economica perché poi vorrei ricordare
che siamo il secondo paese
manifatturiero europeo non abbiamo nulla
da invidiare in termini di tecnologia
altri paesi nel mondo
prima perché c'era in sala c'era un
bolognese doc che parlava di toyota
carrelli elevatori che vengono prodotti
in italia progettate in italia da parte
dei giapponesi quindi insomma non è che
ce la caviamo col male e facciamo però
un confronto con i dna delle imprese
digitali e il credo che tutti
concordiamo che le imprese digitali sono
state create in silicon valley e
cerchiamo di capire come hanno avuto
genesi beh innanzitutto è un progetto a
tavolino stanford oltre che essere un
università è il nome di un signore che a
un certo punto come governatore della
california ha detto serve un'università
che sia in grado di fare due cose che ha
due funzioni obiettivo produrre talenti
nel mondo dell'elettronica e produrre
imprenditori che siano questi gli stessi
studenti oi professori
serve una università che sia in grado da
fare incubatore di impresa e quindi ha
fondato l'università che ha sfornato
calibri di hewlett packard famosi per la
capi fondata nel
garage molti dei fanatici apple
vorrebbero che fosse stata una idea di
steve jobs ma no non mi dicesse
chiuderli è un qualcosa fatto da capire
il 1939 con un obiettivo molto chiaro
voler essere leader nel mercato
dell'elettronica ancora il concetto
digitale non esisteva ma quella era la
funzione obiettivo per loro bastava
questo bastavano un disegno
universitario all incubazione d'impresa
no servivano capitali i capitali sono
fondamentali per lanciare le imprese e
anche qua diciamo che hanno fatto molto
bene e in particolari come hanno
disegnato la possibilità di introdurre
capitali nel sistema in modo virtuoso in
modo tale che anche gli imprenditori
dell'economia tradizionale fossero
incentivati a investire in queste start
up innovative e hanno creato un decreto
governativo che si chiamava small
business investment act e che nei fatti
consentiva alle piccole realtà alle
start up di essere finanziate
all'ottanta per cento dal governo ora
perché esperto di start up
vi posso dare questo flash l'atto sulle
start up innovative e fatto in italia
del 2012
ma parliamo di 70 anni prima è un gap
enorme è un gap che ha costruito un
economia basata su unicorni e che è
difficile da recuperare vedete il dato
di investimenti pro capite italia contro
stati uniti
siamo a due ordini di grandezza
differenza è molto complicato anche
perché la funzione obiettivo di quelli
investitori è rappresentata da queste
torri vorrei che fossero le torri di
bologna
e invece che cosa sono sono il numero di
unicorni cioè imprese che hanno un
valore superiore un
presenti in stati uniti cina un altro
paio di paesi importanti ma
dimensionalmente molto diversi e poi
tutti gli altri
lui non compariamo abbiamo un unico
unicorno digitale come piace citare
perché yoox sempre perché l'unico no ed
è di bologna di zola predosa per la
precisione e e poi basta
e poi non siamo stati in grado di
esprimere altri unicorni e quindi altri
altre realtà economiche in grado di
superare il video di valutazione in
grado di primeggiare nel mondo e quindi
ci arrendiamo aquilino lasciamo fare
solo agli americani o ai cinesi
considerate che i cinesi hanno
recuperato questo gap nel giro degli
ultimi 10 15 anni
recentemente era un convegno sulla
crescita dei visi nel mondo e la
crescita nell'edizione il mondo è
totalmente ad appannaggio della cina che
ha recuperato un gap sul unicorni in
modo determinante negli ultimi 15 anni
ma perché perché hanno un mercato
interno incredibile la possibilità di
lanciare un business e di farlo vedere
scalare a dimensioni da unicorno è un
qualcosa che richiede un mercato interno
importante tante persone che adottino lo
stesso comportamento di acquisto e che
utilizzino hoover piuttosto che airbnb i
cinesi non usano whatsapp di stato prima
se ne parlavano usano un chat
no i cinesi hanno la loro amazon
a questo punto mi chiedo se lasciassimo
decidere all'artificio intelligence che
cosa farebbe
non so se vi ricordate cosa è successo
col botto di microsoft nel giro di un
paio di giorni un po osservato quando
succedevano in rete e ha detto beh
essere razzisti parla e se vi dicessimo
studia l'economia digitale del pianeta e
prova applicarla sul contesto italiano
che cosa farebbe
ma probabilmente se quindi resterebbe
verso il facciamoci male colpito si e
investiamo ingenti capitali nel
tentativo di costruire
la nuova air bindi italiana io partirei
da un presupposto diverso visto che i
talenti ce li abbiamo
ringrazio mia figlia che mi ha sgridato
peraltro quando ho preparato questo
switch per te mi ha detto che in italia
ma ogni tanto abbiamo i talenti abbiamo
giovani abbiamo un'economia tradizionale
forte su cui abbiamo meccanica
meccatronica
abbiamo una serie di talenti che ci
hanno contraddistinto che ci riconoscono
nel mondo ricordiamoci che non è una
prerogativa che ci aiuta attribuiamo nel
mondo riconoscono questa nostra
predominanza nel mondo della meccanica e
allora proviamo a coniugare questo dna
di impresa e di manifattura con un
meccanismo che se volete è di leadership
digitale applicata a questo mondo è un
concetto astruso e allora nel preparare
l'intervento mi sono chiesto come riesco
a renderlo in maniera efficace
va trovato estremamente l'ispirazione
questa immagine e pisa e kit erika
dipinto su
palazzo storico un murales e quello che
richiama è un modo di ristrutturare
quella che è la nostra economia con un
approccio da leader non dà una mano di
bianco non cerco di rinfrescare quello
che stiamo facendo da oggi ma cerco di
reinterpretare e appoggiare uno strato
di economia digitale
no questa ristrutturazione fatta da un
leader della pop art e di inventarmi una
nuova economia e ma non bastano solo i
pennelli colori per recuperare un gap
che è stato costruito negli anni
nell'arco di un centro di chi meno 100
anni e non basta neanche il fatto che i
capitali che abbiamo noi non possono
paragonarsi per i cinesi che quindi
hanno disegnato un progetto per
l'economia digitale del paese e in
vent'anni circa hanno costruito tanti
ricordi quanti quelli negli stati uniti
servono scuole ma non scuole
tradizionali non l'università servono
scuole di imprenditori l'imprenditoria
digitale serve una scuole che ci
insegnano modelli di comportamento che
ci insegnano i meccanismi con cui fare
impresa digitale che ci aiutino a
imparare dalle esperienze che sono già
state fatte in passato in modo tale da
mettere a fattor comune per il futuro
serve
in sostanza dal nostro punto di vista
dal mio punto di vista applicare questo
leur di economia digitale sopra
l'economia tradizionale
dobbiamo aiutare le imprese di oggi che
se non si modernizzano avranno
sicuramente problemi nei prossimi 10
quei dieci anni a essere competitive e
l'unico modo per farlo e aiutarle con
artifici anni termini con nuove
tecnologie con questo strato digitale
modo tale da creare una classe dirigente
imprenditoriale digitale che sembra di
affiancare prima l'economia del paese
odierna e negli anni
di sostituirla e costruire leader
digitali del nostro prossimo futuro è la
mia esortazione in questo senso è
trovare i meccanismi come avvenne ai
tempi di mecenate con virgilio affinché
gli imprenditori dell'economia
tradizionali diventino i mecenati per il
leader digitali e lo diventino non solo
con capitali ed economia che serve
perché i capitali servono avete visto
siamo troppo piccole nei confronti degli
stati uniti ma serve anche che diventino
i loro champion il loro tester
dobbiamo avere la fiducia da parte degli
imprenditori tradizionali di far testare
le nuove tecnologie nei loro ambienti
produttivi
altrimenti costruire queste imprese
digitale in laboratorio non è possibile
è estremamente complicato il mercato
deve aiutare le imprese digitali a
crescere e questo concetto di
mecenatismo è fondamentale per riuscire
a costruire questa nuova classe che deve
esprimere talenti calibri del ordine di
grandezza di ferrari
gli interni di eccellenza tecnologica e
non dimensionale
non dobbiamo creare qui unicorni
business to business
dobbiamo creare delle eccellenze
tecnologiche in grado di primeggiare per
non lasciare nelle mani dell'artificiale
intelligence il futuro del paese